Donald Trump is struggling in the polls
lately because he has low approval
ratings among many key groups like women
minorities young people people who are
shoes when they go to work and those who
want the President to have a basic grasp
of decency and grammar now our research
hasn't covered yet another key
demographic that's coming out against
Trump who is it a hoverboard enthusiast
be the cast of the 1993 action movie
demolition man very specific group or
see cats Jimmy
cats because his hair looks like he just
murdered one yes
brother yeah the answer of course when
it's always on the show and it's a
question of cats answers always cats
let's take a look
the cat has recognized the beast this
will surely turn the internet against
Trump because cats are so beloved
obviously all this knows that bigger
- us yes uh I do think I do
something he could do to get them back
classic classic okay all over him okay
I know keyboard Trump